je vous propose maintenant puisque nous
sommes à la fin de l'année de nous
arrêter un instant sur l'un des grands
phénomènes qui ont marqué cette année
1983 nous ferons d'ailleurs tout au long
des jours qui viennent cherchant à
dégager les grandes tendances les grands
thèmes de réflexion de l'année passée
aujourd'hui c'est l'un des phénomènes
les plus troublants que je vous propose
de réfléchir sur lequel je vous propose
de réfléchir
il s'agit du racisme le racisme qui
s'est développé ces derniers mois et qui
a fait une trentaine de morts en france
un chiffre qui paraît incroyable une
montée du racisme donc qui s'inscrit sur
fond de crise économique et dont nous
avons tous à un moment ou un autre été
témoin marcel trillât un homme est mort
dans le bandeau vintimille
le 15 novembre dernier un algérien de
passage en france pour quelques jours
habib renzi 26 ans
dans le top 20 trois jeunes français
partis s'engager dans la légion
sous-officier qui les accompagnent cette
endormi alors il se met en chasse tombe
par hasard sur cette étrange et
s'acharne contre lui dans le wagon
personne ne bouge
au petit jour entre montauban et
castelsarrasin
on retrouve son cadavre sur le ballast
le lendemain la france entière a pu voir
ces images
les trois auteurs de cet acte
et surtout ce regard
le soir de juillet dernier c'est un père
de famille sans histoire qui tire à la
carabine
le l'une de ses fenêtres de la cité des
4000 à la courneuve il fait chaud aux
pieds des immeubles des groupes
d'enfants maghrébins qui joue avec des
fêtards parmi eux
toufik 10 ans
sophie il a allumé un pétard
il a allumé alors n'attendez plus
après il s'est retourné il a reçu la
balle ce qu'on m'a dit après il a
commencé à marcher à marcher vers moi je
vais qu'est ce qui t'arrive marché
j'ai mal touché au coeur tout si bien
mourir au pied de l'immeuble sur ce bord
de pierre à qui la faute
la canicule peut-être l'entassement
danser termitière de banlieue le chômage
l'insécurité
et puis la haine le refus de côtoyer
celui qui diffèrent et l'on pût pour
cela de plus en plus trente fois en 1983
il ya aussi tous ceux qui tuent à blanc
avec les mots ou avec des lettres comme
celle là
grand bravo pour ces jeunes militaires
et les autres qui ont tué les [ __ ] on
en a marre des [ __ ] algériens et
même des maigres la france aux français
qui reflète le clan dans leur bled et
qu'ils y crèvent de faim et sept autres
un seul rachat possible distribuer la
pilule gratuitement à toutes les vaches
reproductive de ces éternels mendiants
il y en a même qui n'hésitent plus
aujourd'hui à signer ce genre de lettre
ou à dire tous des mots comme cela et
pourtant c'est à domicile qu'on est allé
les chercher en espagne au maroc ou
ailleurs
il n'y a pas si longtemps la france
avait besoin de bras immigrés officiel
immigrés clandestins
il y avait toujours du travail pour du
travail mal payé celui dont les français
ne voulaient plus
j'en ai besoin de 3 comment taper
doubler le taux rémunérant qu'elle
chantait toujours dire numéro lui
paris dix ou vingt ans après plus de
deux millions de chômeurs
en 1980 on a régularisé la situation de
120000 sans papiers maintenant la france
se protègent les nouveaux venus sont de
trop à peine arrivés ils se retrouvent
dans l'avion du retour
mais il ya les autres les réguliers ceux
qui sont nés en france emploie environ 4
millions d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
pour certains un épouvantail bien
commode un argument électoral comme à
dreux en septembre dernier aux élections
partielles est un argument qui paye
jean-claude stirbois front national
extrême droite 17% des voix au premier
tour
allié au deuxième tour avec l'udf et le
rpr jean claude cyr bois devient adjoint
au maire à droite
simone veil seul désapprouvent à gauche
beaucoup de protestations
quelques communiqué rien de plus et puis
le 15 octobre le maigre cortège de la
marche de l'égalité
seize au départ de marseille un mois et
demi plus tard de la bastille à
montparnasse la croisade pour
financieele s'est mué en manifestation
géant
soixante mille personnes
une foule métis comme la société
française enrichie de tout temps par les
graisses des immigrations successives
malgré tout les roger malgré les
assassins du bordeaux vintimille
là